and we will by the end of this year
assuming that the vikings and saints
game goes forward as
scheduled on christmas day there will
have been
an nfl game played every day of the week
and that leads into something that we've
kicked around from time to time i wrote
something about this yesterday
yeah definitely a thought come on in
some of the upper reaches of the league
to expand the windows now
this isn't because hey people seem to
like tuesday night football they seem to
like
wednesday night football they seem to
like double headers on mondays
this is an anticipation of where the
the puck is moving as it relates to
gambling
because at some point before too long
you think how much the world's changed
since may of 2018 when the supreme court
opened the floodgates for every state
to adopt legalize sports wagering and
and it's still
changing all the time at some point you
will
be able while watching a game
you will be seeing in real time what's
happening in the stadium the latency
issue will be gone so when you pick up
your cell phone device
and you make a bet on what's going to
happen on the next play you can lock it
in
there's no chance that someone knows
what's already occurred
what you see in your home is what's
happening in the stadium once we get to
that point
the market and the reason and the
motivation chris for having as few games
on as possible will be significant
because they want people to get engaged
with one game yeah they want that action
on one game right on one you know let's
watch this one game yeah and let's bet
on whether or not it's gonna be a run or
a pass we're gonna score a touchdown or
a field goal on this drive
um and and if you have seven games going
on at once
you're wasting opportunities to create
this one thing yeah that uh you know
millions of people can focus on
and wager on at once that that's what's
driving this thought
of creating more windows whether it's
more windows on sunday
the early morning game that we see in
london from time to time
two games on monday a game on tuesday a
game on wednesday a game on thursday you
can play every day except
friday and saturday friday and saturday
is prohibited by the nfl's broadcast and
a trust exemption to protect high school
and college football
the other five days of the week it's
open season and i'm not saying this is
going to be in the next tv
contract but that's where the puck is
moving
get ready for this reality
and and you know what it could move
there faster because
people like having these games on
tuesday and wednesday night i i didn't
know what to do with myself last night
no i didn't either i love it i i mean i
i think the nfl is crazy not to get in
like
in you know involved in the next tv
deals
like let's go it's the market's there
who cares and
you're i mean so many games in general
just get lost in the shuffle on sunday
one o'clock oh there's seven games going
on eight games
like that nobody knows or cares about
some of them to know what's going on or
any of that
you know it goes on in other sports and
i think what we
learned this year and i think we could
do it even better
but we've learned that we can move
schedules and manage and
find it out the right way you know
they're have to do the right thing as
far as player safety
and figure out how to make sure they
give teams the proper rest and figure
out the right way to do it
but i would think logistically and all
that that they could figure out to have
those games
you know all nights of the week and i i
i think it's great you know i
hey you over at england and soccer and
they play all nights of the week
every all the time um i don't understand
why we can't do that now and i think
this year has proven we're capable of
pulling it off i just got to do it the
right way i don't want to see
what we saw with the ravens and steelers
this past week where you know they're
going to play two games in four days or
two games in five days and do that we
gotta limit that stuff to just once in a
while type of
you know scenario well and and you know
i've heard the argument that maybe it's
time to bring the second buy back they
experimented with that back in 1993 and
18
i remember that for 16 games right so
you could you could go with you know you
you play on a tuesday or a wednesday and
then you have your buy that weekend as
the case may be or you know you can have
the same team play wednesday and
wednesday you could have played
wednesday and wednesday or two or
tuesday and wednesday right or monday
and tuesday or tuesday and monday
there's a lot of flexibility there is i
i
it will it will not be something that
howard katz and the scheduling folks
embrace
uh as a positive because it will
complicate their lives chris the other
thing too is to the extent that
you know you start moving games around
and flexing games you do get
you do get fan expectations in play
where i've got tickets to a game at four
o'clock on sunday wait it's tuesday now
while i'm supposed to be out of town on
tuesday
that you know so i don't think they
could go that far no i don't think they
can either
but you could structure the schedule
right
in april and everyone knows when the
games are going to be yeah and and look
do you run the risk of having a stinker
on a on a wednesday night in december
yes
but if people are just looking for
things to bet on
i mean look we got to be realistic about
it the supreme court opened this
pandora's box this box full of pandora
he's in there
she's in there and and and
once it fully matures it doesn't matter
if it's jaguar remember when jaguars
titans was that thursday night game that
we were like oh god
every year again this year and the
jaguars are wearing the mustard uniforms
and
and it just was an awful display oh no
now it's
it's uh hey you know what's going to
happen this drive and how many
how many touchdowns will will tennessee
score if it is a bad game like that so
it's it's there and i feel like it's
coming
i just don't know how soon it's gonna
come but
and it's not because chris you and i
like it it's because there's a lot of
money
to be made by breaking those games out
of that
seven eight or nine game cluster at one
o'clock eastern on
a sunday yeah that's what i don't like
just that cluster that's probably my one
big negative
of all nfl scheduling right now is you
know as
or our job and as a fan it's just it's
it's just a lot to watch
yeah forget the job but even as a fan
before i got in this job and had that
year
where i sat out of football man you used
to drive me crazy at one o'clock trying
to
sit on the couch watch all the games get
a feel for what's going on or
there might be three really good games
going on that have implications you're
like damn i just can't pay attention to
all of them uh
if they could fix that i mean it would
be awesome the first sunday of football
season when you have waited months
to watch a game that counts and you have
this explosion of activity
that overloads the senses i've said many
times it's the equivalent of coming down
the stairs on christmas morning and
having all of your presence unwrap
themselves simultaneously
it's too much it's too much there's
there's a better way to do it that
allows football fans to focus
to enjoy to appreciate and ultimately
to wager their hard-earned money on
whether or not
they're going to run the ball pass the
ball score a touchdown do whatever
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports